An elderly woman watches from her living room
window as heavy sheets of rainfall outside.
She rocks back and forth in her chair nervously.
“It’s been raining for days.
The road is washed out.
I can’t get to town.
What am I to do?
What am I to do?”
she says out loud to herself.
The rocking chair creaks under her weight,
but not as much as it had three days ago,
before she ran out of food.
“I am so hungry,” the old lady moans.
She glances at the door that leads to her
basement.
“Maybe I can find something to eat down
there.”
She stands up, her 90-year-old bones creak,
as she slowly shuffles towards the basement
door.
The empty chair rocks back and forth from
the old woman’s momentum as if someone is
still sitting in it.
She opens the door and looks into the pitch-black
darkness.
There are no windows down there, the only
light is connected to a drawstring in the
middle of the room.
The old woman slowly makes her way down the
uneven wooden steps.
When she reaches the bottom, she reaches out
her wrinkled hand, groping in the darkness
for the drawstring.
Her hand brushes something, it feels like
sticky yarn.
Then she feels the legs of a spider scurry
up her arm.
The old woman lets out a shriek as her hand
locates the string, and she pulls hard.
The light flickers on.
It creates a dim glow, but at least she can
now see what’s in the basement.
The string swings back and forth casting a
snake-like shadow on the far wall.
The old woman scans the floor for anything
to eat: a leftover tuna can, some pickled
vegetables, a rat, anything will do at this
point.
There is nothing there.
The old woman feels her strength has been
almost completely drained.
She doesn’t know how she’ll make it back
up the stairs.
In desperation, she looks around the basement
one last time.
Her eyes fall on an old rusty saw.
She pauses for a moment.
“I need to eat,” she whispers.
The old woman slowly walks towards the saw.
She picks it up and examines it.
“God gave me two hands for a reason,”
she says, her eyes locked on the rusty blade.
She places one hand on the wooden workbench
that sits against the wall and grips the saw
tightly with the other.
The old woman takes a deep breath and brings
the saw down towards her hand…
“Where are we going?”
D-94-322 asks the SCP agent driving the car.
“House on Hadley Hill,” the agent responds.
“Well, that doesn’t sound creepy at all.”
D-94-322 says as he cranes his neck to get
a glimpse of the top of the mountain through
the SUV window.
“Why don’t we just play the quiet game
until we get there,” the agent says as he
focuses on the pothole-riddled back roads
of Mt.
Zion, Georgia.
D-94-322 holds on tightly to the handhold
above him to keep his body from slamming into
the door every time they go over a big bump.
They continue on for a few more minutes when
a rundown house comes into view.
The agent pulls off the road and stops the
SUV.
“Here you go,” he says, handing D-94-322
an earpiece.
“What am I supposed to do with this?”
D-94-322 asks.
“Just stick it in your ear,” the agent
says with just a little contempt in his voice.
“You don’t have to be rude about it,”
D-94-322 replies as he grabs the earbud and
sticks it in his ear.
“Hello, testing, anybody out there?”
“Hello, D-94-322, can you hear me?” says
a voice in his head.
“Uhh, yeah, you can just call me D94 for
short.
D-94-322 is kinda a mouthful.”
“Very well,” the voice from the earbud
agrees.
“My name is Dr. Andrews.
I will be walking you through this test with
SCP-4173.”
“Alright Doc, shall we get this party started?”
D94 says as he steps out of the SUV.
He looks up at the house that sits atop Hadley
Hill.
The sky is dark, and clouds race over the
mountain as if they would rather be anywhere
else but here.
“Here we go.”
D94 starts walking up the slippery hill, being
careful not to fall.
He reaches the overgrown walkway leading up
to the house and pauses.
“Is there a problem?”
Dr. Andrews asks.
“No, just trying to psych myself up to go
into this creepy house,” responds D94.
“What’s inside anyways?”
“That’s not your concern at the moment.
But if you do exactly as I tell you, you should
be in and out in no time.”
“Whatever you say Doc.”
D94 walks down the path, reaches his hand
out, and grips the cool brass knob.
He turns it and pushes the door open.
The inside of the house smells like mothballs
and decay.
“Alright, I’m in,” he says
“Good.
Head down the hallway and turn to your left.
You’ll see a door that leads to the basement.
Let me know when you’re there.”
D94 walks down the hallway, the old wooden
floor groans under his feet.
He reaches the basement door; it is slightly
ajar.
“This place gives me the creeps.”
“Rightfully so,” Dr. Andrews chimes in.
“It is an old spooky house on top of an
old spooky hill in the middle of nowhere.
Obviously, it is going to be creepy.
An old woman died here under mysterious circumstances
around 20 years ago.
But you don’t really need to worry about
that.
No ghosts here…
I think.”
“You think?”
D94 shouts as he takes a step away from the
basement door.
“I’m just kidding.
There’s nothing but harmless old SCP-4173
in that house.
And when has an SCP ever hurt anyone, right?”
There is a long uncomfortable pause.
“Anyways, why don’t you head on downstairs
so we can get you out of there as soon as
possible!”
“Yeah, sure,” D94 says as he begins his
descent into the darkness.
“I can’t see anything.
Is there a light?”
“No, I think it burnt out years ago.
But that’s okay; I can guide you.
It’s what I’m here for,” says Dr. Andrews.
“Walk towards the east wall, but watch your
head; the ceiling is low in that corner.
You'll see what you’re looking for when
you get there.”
D94 is silent for a moment.
“East?” he asks.
“Turn left,” Dr. Andrews responds.
“Oh, alright, why didn’t you say so Doc?”
D94 turns to the left and walks forward.
After a few feet, there is a loud bang as
he slams his head into the ceiling.
“Son of a—”
“I told you to watch your head.”
“Yeah, thanks,” says D94 as he rubs the
bump forming beneath his hair.
“This place is even spookier than the first
floor; you know that, right?”
“I promise there is nothing in that room
right now that can hurt you,” Dr. Andrews
reassures D94.
“Wait, what do you mean right now?”
“Don’t worry about it.
Just let me know when you reach the wall D94.”
After a few seconds, D94’s eyes adjust to
the darkness.
He can just make out the damp concrete wall
in front of him.
It looks as if the wall is perspiring.
“I’m here,” he says.
“Good.
There's a little door, maybe five feet to
your left.
You see it?” asks Dr. Andrews.
D94 turns.
“Yeah, I see it.
It's closed.”
The door itself is not very big, maybe a foot
long and half a foot wide.
“Open it,” says Dr. Andrew.
D94 hesitates.
“What’s in there?”
“Nothing, just open it,” Dr. Andrews repeats
himself.
“No way man.
You’re lying, and I’m not opening anything
until you tell me what’s on the other side
of that door.”
Dr. Andrews sighs.
“We both know that you’re going to do
as I say D-94-322.
You have no other choice.
Unless you want to go back to that death row
cell block where we found you.”
D94 shakes his head and rubs the bridge of
his nose.
“Fine,” he says.
Dr. Andrews can hear the squeaking of hinges
through the microphone on the D94’s earbud.
“It’s open; now what?”
“Do you see anything?”
“Um, no.
There are some cobwebs and dirt, but other
than that, it’s just dark.”
D94 thinks for a moment.
“Why is this little door here?
Is this some pet door or something?
You'd have to be…
I dunno, pretty small to get in there.”
“Agreed.
Just hang tight, and let me know when you
hear something.
We won't keep you there long.”
“Hear something?
Like what?” asks D94.
“You’ll know when you hear it,” says
Dr. Andrews.
5 minutes go by without a sound.
Then 10.
15.
The basement is damp and cold.
D94 thinks he sees creatures scurrying around
the floor, but he doesn’t say anything because
acknowledging them makes his situation more
real, and a lot more scary.
After a half-hour of waiting in silence, D94
screams.
“What the heck was that?”
“What was what?”
Dr. Andrews is startled out of a daydream
by the shouts of D94 in his ear.
“Something just moved past the door!
I definitely saw it.
What in God’s name was that?”
yells D94.
Dr. Andrews tries to remain calm, but he can
barely contain his excitement.
“The entity in the wall is why you're down
there.”
“What do you mean?
You said there wasn’t anything down here!”
“I said there was nothing down there that
could hurt you.
If you follow my instructions, this will continue
to be true.
Can you hear anything?” asks Dr. Andrews.
“No I can’t hear any—” but before
D94 can finish his sentence, a voice speaks
from behind the wall.
He can’t understand what the voice is saying
at first, but as his heart begins to slow
and the blood stops thumping in his ears,
D94 can make out her words.
“Oh thank goodness.
I wasn't sure you'd be able to find me.
What took you so long?” says the voice of
an old woman.
D94 takes a step back from the door.
“There’s someone on the other side of
that wall?” he hisses into the microphone
at Dr. Andrews.
“Tell it that the road is out, and you had
to find another way up,” says Dr. Andrews
in D94’s earpiece.
“What?
Why?”
“Just do it if you want to get out of there,
D94.”
Dr. Andrews says a little impatiently.
“Uh, the road is out; I had to find another
way up,” says D94 to the little open door
in the wall.
“Oh yes, the rain washed it out.
I was worried I wouldn't ever get to see another
person again, being stuck up here and all.
Can you see me?” asks the voice.
“Um, no, I can’t,” says D94.
“Doc, what is on the other side of that
wall?”
“Come over here a little closer; I can't
see you properly either,” says the voice.
“It's fine; you can get closer.
Just don't touch the door,” Dr. Andrews
says.
“I really don’t want to do that,” says
D94.
“Do it, and you will be that much closer
to getting out.”
“I hate you,” whispers D94.
He slowly approaches the little door and speaks
into it.
“Hello?”
“Oh, there you are.”
The voice pauses as if whoever is speaking
is examining D94.
“I'm sorry, I can't see like I used to.
It's so dark in here, and it's been so long.
Reach through the door and let me feel your
hand, so I can tell you're really there.”
“What?”
D94 steps away from the door.
“No way am I putting my hand in there.”
“Come now, don't be rude.
I just want to feel that you're there.
It's been so long.
Just a touch,” the voice says a little harsher
than before.
“Screw you, lady!
I'm not getting my hands anywhere near this
creepy hole in the wall,” says D94.
He turns around and starts walking away from
the little door towards the staircase leading
back to the main level of the house.
Before he can put his foot on the first step,
D94 hears Dr. Andrew’s voice screaming in
his ear.
“Stop moving!
Look, you're going to have to do it.
We haven't been able to recover anyone who
refuses to do what she asks.
I can't guarantee your safety unless you put
your hand through that door.”
“Are you kidding me?”
shouts D94.
“You’re telling me that sweet, creepy,
old lady will somehow kill me if I don’t
do as she asks?”
“We’re not entirely sure what happens,
but you need to put your hand through that
door if you want to get out of there,” says
Dr. Andrews.
D94 turns back toward the little door and
slowly approaches it.
“This is my nightmare,” he says more to
himself than anyone else.
He reaches out slowly and puts his fingers
through the doorway.
He immediately pulls them back and steps away
from the door.
“I really don’t want to do this,” D94
whispers.
He steps forward again and sticks his hand
all the way through the doorway.
For a moment, nothing happens.
“Alright, I've got my hand in there.
Now what?”
“Oh, I can see you now.
You're right there.
Thank you for coming.
It has been so long since someone came, and
with a gift as well?
Sweetling, you're so kind.
So kind to me.”
“Gift?
What gift?”
D94 asks nervously.
“It's so dark and lonesome, and I've just
been so hungry for such a long time.
Thank you sweetling.
I'll take your gift from you.
You are such a rude little brat, you don't
really deserve it.
You've had it for too long, and you don't
deserve it.
It's mine now.
Mine for my belly.
Thank you.”
“What are you talking about, you psycho?”
D94 stutters.
Suddenly, something grabs his hand and pulls
him against the wall.
He screams in agony as Dr. Andrews hears a
wet ripping sound coming through the microphone.
It sounds as if some type of metal instrument
is cutting through flesh.
“Oh, God!
No!
Help me!
Help me!”
D94 screams.
“Please!
Please!
Ple—” Dr. Andrews hears the sound of D94’s
body hitting the floor as he passes out.
It is quiet for a moment.
“Don't worry, you ungrateful child.
Don't worry.
I'll fill you up too.
You can have mine.
I'll give it to you.
Sweet boy.
Good boy.
Fill you up,” says the old woman’s voice
from the other side of the wall.
Dr. Andrews listens as the hinges of the little
door squeak, and it clicks shut.
He picks up the phone next to him and dials
it.
“Go in and get him.
Bring him back to Site-94 for observation.
And try to keep this one alive, please.”
He hangs up the phone and prepares the lab
for D-94-322 to be brought in.
D94 slowly comes out of his medically induced
coma two days after the incident with SCP-4173.
He is stable but doesn’t feel great, and
he can’t help but sense that something is
different.
He brings his arm up to scratch his face but
feels nothing.
D94 looks at where his hand should be.
There is nothing there.
“That crazy old lady ate my hand!” he
starts screaming.
A medical team rushes in as red lights begin
to flash and sirens blare.
They attempt to restrain D94.
During the struggle, D94 catches a glimpse
of himself in a mirror on the far side of
the room.
He stops fighting for a moment.
There is a growth expanding from his head.
“What the heck is that?” he yells, pointing
to his reflection.
D94 begins to struggle again, this time much
more intensely.
He begins scratching at the growth on the
side of his head without much success.
In the process, he pushes the growth further
into his skull.
It penetrates his brain.
D94 blacks out.
The medical team ties D94 to the bed and tries
to get a reading on his vitals.
The growth is putting too much pressure on
his brain.
They rush him to the ER, but D-94-322 dies
before he reaches the operating table.
Dr. Andrews stands over the body of the deceased
Class-D subject.
“Cut him open,” he says to the doctors
standing in the room.
One of them pulls out a scalpel and makes
an incision into the side of D94’s head.
“What is that?”
one of the doctors says.
The other bends over to get a better look.
After a moment he turns away and vomits into
his face mask.
Dr. Andrews picks up a pair of forceps off
the table.
He sticks them deep into the hole in the side
of D94’s head and clamps down hard.
Dr. Andrews pulls out a decomposing hand.
The fingers are still moving as if trying
to grab onto something.
There is no explanation for how it got in
there, but it is obvious that SCP-4173 played
some sort of role in the phenomena.
Dr. Andrews goes back to his office to review
previous case files on SCP-4173.
Everyone who has put their hand into the small
doorway has been pulled towards the wall and
had their hand chopped off.
The severed appendage never ends up being
a clean-cut, which leads Dr. Andrews to hypothesize
the gruesome makeshift operation is done with
some sort of tool with teeth.
Once the hand of the victim is severed, SCP-4173
always thanks the person for their gift.
She then informs them not to worry about their
hand as it will be replaced.
But then something incredibly strange happens.
Like with D94, a decaying hand will appear
somewhere in the body, but it isn’t always
inside the head.
In fact, depending on how polite the test
subject is to the old woman behind the door,
the closer to the wrist the decaying hand
actually ends up.
For the test subjects who are rude to the
old lady, the decaying hand ends up in some
pretty interesting places.
“She really hated D-94-322,” chuckles
Dr. Andrews to himself.
Dr. Andrews continues flipping to the back
of the file on SCP-4173.
The SCP Foundation doesn’t quite know how
it happens, but people who refuse to offer
their hand to SCP-4173 suffer a worse fate
than those who surrender to the old lady.
In every case where a subject tries to get
away from the small door, some inexplicable
force seems to grab them from behind and drag
them through the tiny opening.
In these cases, there is nothing left of the
test subject It is likely fatal as a human
is much smaller than the opening itself, so
the only way a body could fit through the
doorway is if every bone is broken and every
muscle compressed to a quarter of its actual
size.
“I’m not sure which is worse,” Dr. Andrews
says aloud as he closes the file on SCP-4173.
He glances at the picture paperclipped to
the front of the manila folder depicting the
tiny doorway.
He can’t quite pinpoint why, but the fact
that the door slowly closes after the old
woman gets what she needs from her victims
sends chills down his spine.
The words of the old woman echo in his head:
“Don't worry.
I'll fill you up too.
You can have mine.
I'll give it to you.
Sweet boy.
Good boy.
Fill you up.”
Now go check out “SCP-2696 Haunted Victorian
Mansion” and “SCP-1461 - House of the
Worm” for more frightening anomalous locations!